when I read the I'll be back line I said
the gym camera is it the me it sounds
weird when I said I'll be back as it's
about how would you say that's it I will
be back and he says no pumping iron well
interestingly enough pumping iron was a
documentary about explaining
bodybuilding it was not about me because
you never know who is going to win doing
stay hungry the film that it did before
pumping iron
I had to reduce my body weight down to
210 so the question was really can I
come back again with 240 pounds and
didn't win the mr. Olympia gains if
there was questionable so therefore no
one really focused on me per se but they
focused more on bodybuilding itself I
just happened to emerge as the
personality in the bodybuilding field
and so that's why the cameras were
didn't warn me I happened to win the
competition against some tough
competitions against do for ignore for
instance in surgeon to pray and Franco
Columbu and guys like that they were
really tough competitors I think it was
all that lent itself for me being myself
so I think that people didn't onlys just
see me and stay hungry as an actor but
this all of a sudden what I'm really
like so I got you know the Conan the
Barbarian because of pumping iron it was
like the movie where I showed my
personality and hit Pressman saw that
movie pumping iron and said this finally
thought we found the guy that is the
personality and has the acting ability
and has the body they be able to play
Conan the Barbarian
Franco is pretty smart but Franco is a
child and when it comes to the day of
the contest I'm his father
he comes to me for advisors so it's a
dead heart for me to give him
the wrong advises the saying in a milk
is for babies and you know I drink beer
you know that is because of me Munich
days so when I moved from Austria to
Munich to train between the age of 19
and 21 other teams always would have
milk bottles all over the windows that
were empty or half for for that
bodybuilders will be drinking in our gym
Mia downstairs a restaurant and we
always got the huge Stein's of beer so
we had just beer all around the windows
and around the gymnasium and I refused
to drink in the milk because I hated
milk and so beer was really for me to
drink to have while I was working out
[Music]
bumping on is being shown just about in
all the gyms around the world 24 hours a
day so it doesn't matter which
generation you talk about the new
generation that is walking and now into
the gym still see pumping on and it
still see me winning and so when they
come to gorgeous gym here now in Venice
you know they know everything about me I
think that this movie is has his life is
his own life and he will go on forever I
think and I think that it is really one
of those greater commanders that really
has established bodybuilding in a big
way because bodybuilding was kind of
like a you know a hidden kind of a sport
it was no one really understood it no
one really could explain what it is
about and I think that pumping iron did
all of that did explain that Conan the
Barbarian my goal was to be a leading
man and I was told many times by
managers and agents and studio
executives that this will never happen
that someone with an accent like me has
never become a real leading man and a
big star in America that Americans like
to hear
people sound like John Wayne or Clint
Eastwood but not like me
that may be good for Hogan's Heroes if
they ever make a remake or something
like that but definitely not for any
other movie and also that my body is way
too big
that I'm too large and so here over
sudden is Conan the Barbarian where my
accent was welcome because I talk
different than everyone else and it
looks like from some prehistoric time
and the body looked like an action hero
somewhat something that like Frank
Frazetta when he drew the Conan
characters in the comic books he always
drew him with the huge muscles very
defined and rip but then those days
there was no act around the devil could
play that role so here was me so over
setting those two things that they
always were complaining about and said
that that will never make you a star
because you have too big of a body guys
like Dustin Hoffman and Al Pacino and
Woody Allen there's at the in guys in
the 70s not a big body like that and the
accent doesn't work all of this became
an asset rather than a liability so I
proved to the world again never listen
to the naysayers and always just plow
ahead and do exactly what his you vision
my vision was to become a big star and
to become not only a big star but we've
become the highest paid entertainer
ended field which I eventually then
became when they did Batman and Robin
twenty years of pitiless Kumbha no rest
no sleep I got a man this was really the
only movie where I had more
responsibility of doing my own stunts
than any other movie because there was
no one around no stunt guy that hit the
same body
so Terry Leonard the time of the wide
shots meant from far away when you see
conan riding under horse or something
like that he would do that because you
know with the war paint and with the
camouflage paint on and all that stuff
we got away with it but then close-ups
there was no way because he had an
ordinary kind of athletic body but not a
bodybuilders body like I had or like the
Tollman body so I had to end up doing a
lot of the force a lot of the sword
fights loved
the things and horses that big barrels
and horses off this crashing together
with versus falling off the worst of the
stuff I had to do myself
and luckily I was young enough to
sustain the punishment because there
were a lot of injuries at that time I
remember the first day I shot I had to
get stitched up I had 12 stitches on my
back because some wolf pulled me down
from the rocks and I fell with my back
on rocks it was all of it from the
beginning that I had really wild and the
great experience and John Milius the
director loved it he says this is
exactly what it's all about this is a
tough movie to shoot and this is a
colony era and this is exactly the way
we want it noticer he really got off on
all those kind of things
terminator when I was hired to do
Terminator I really think I mean the day
maybe the studio executives that were
around then and that and various
different people will tell it
differently because they always say I
told you so a type of thing but the
reality of was I think the treated is
like as a b-movie as a be action movie
it's just another one because of the
year before came out exterminator
now it was terminated and then what else
is gonna be next type of thing right but
when I shot the film and Jim Cameron
showed me some of the footage and then
when he had like 20 minutes edited and I
saw the film I said to myself wait a
minute
this is a really intense this is wild
I mean I don't think we've ever seen
anything like this before
in a way it was shot the way it was lit
the way it was directed everything the
way it was written he was just really
very very special and so I thought then
I think this could be bigger than we all
think and then sure enough when it came
out he was a huge hit and even Time
magazine listed it amongst its top ten
movies of the year so no one expected
that in those days like for instance
when you open up a film to four million
dollars a weekend it was big time and
you know especially in the fall and then
the next weekend it was again for a
million dollars and then the next
weekend it was again for a million so it
didn't have any drop so
oh my god what's going on here so the
movie was highly successful a lot of
people saw it and it was actually in
this particular case it was the audience
that demanded a sequel nice night for a
walk
wash day tomorrow nothing clean right
nothing clean right this guy's a couple
kids short of a six-pack your clothes
give them to me
now when I read the I'll be back line I
said the gym camera is it the me it
sounds weird when I said I'll be back as
this is about how would you say that's
it I will be back and he says no I think
it sounds better I'll be back I said
well it's more machine like music I will
be back is this look I don't correct you
acting don't correct my writing okay and
that there was it and so he says look we
just say ten times in a row I say we
just say it and say it said and then we
get it right and then we can pick one or
the other I understand that you don't
feel comfortable we did it yeah how
enorus but lettuce chewy and so that's
what we did but not first of all I
thought it was a clumsy or or a line and
number two and of course had no idea
that anyone would ever repeat it period
when the movie came out people coming up
to me and says say the line say the line
now Road and I said what lionesses help
you back and I said I'll be back and
said no no no the way you said it in the
movies the way you say in the movie
there was opposite such as in the mood
okay I'll be back you say yeah yeah yeah
oh my god and it was like amazing the
excitement that you saw amongst people
when I said this line and then more and
moist are picking up and other people
started using it and now I think it
became the most used line ever in the
movie history
I'll be back I think that we don't know
ahead of time in the email - it hasta la
vista baby I think it may be the way I
say it that makes him ten kind of unique
because it's like also when we did the
movie in a kindergarten carping us into
the kids it's not a tumor it's not a
tumor at all it's like the way I said to
Mullen orders like it's just been out
choppa you know they don't pronounce the
EOS and all this kind of stuff and I
think that is a lot of times the way I
say but I don't think you ever know when
you look at the script that this line
will be repeated very often Terminator 2
Jim Cameron is just a genius right now
because to come up with this idea to
make the Terminator become a protector
that hangs out with this kid and because
of that relationship
he starts learning human behavior how to
be more cool in other high five and you
know and how to say certain things
certain sayings and orders made it very
very precious I think because he was of
trying very hard you know when the kid
says he never smile you never smile
smile just let's just smile and I would
go like this he says oh my god alright I
did was a good try
and if someone comes up to you with an
attitude we say eat me and if you want
to shine them on its hasta la vie stop
baby
hasta la vista baby it really lends
itself to some funny moments so I think
that it was really important in moving I
think this is why the movie really was
so successful because it was a totally
different spin he is terminated all of a
sudden not the killing machine but a
protector what an interesting spin he
was programmed differently and I think
that people really enjoy that even
though I never killed anybody in
Terminator 2 I only shot people at the
knees and just you know broke their
backs or whatever and blew up the police
cars but it didn't really kill anyone
because the promis'd is the kid that I
would not kill anybody twins the movie
twins which was originally called the
experiment was developed specifically
for me because when I met Ivan Reitman I
said to him I want you to direct me I
want to get into comedy no one will hire
me for comedy because everyone is making
a lot of money of me with action movie
so it's very hard for me to cross over
because people don't want to take the
risks so he said I think that you're
very funny and I think that we should
develop some stuff for you so he
developed five scripts and one of them
was the experiment I fell in love with
that idea and then we changed it to
twins and they came up with the idea to
have Danny DeVito play not only someone
that behaves opposite of me but also
looks totally the opposite I thought
that it was very very funny and because
all your to do is kind of show the
poster obtaining leaning against me and
saying you know only their mother can
tell them apart
I made it made everyone laugh in the
cells so it was hugely successful it was
unbelievable and I was so happy because
he was actually my first movie that made
mastica Lee over a hundred million
dollars and he was a comedy not an
action movie so from then on of course I
could offer a lot of action movies but
Danny and I be rehearsed those scenes
but we just had so much fun on the set
in the rehearsing the scenes and doing
all the same things and having all the
same mannerism in the scratching our
butts at the same time and doing all
this kind of stuff so I think it was
great and it was brilliantly written
I was 12 years old she was a nun
Kindergarten Cop whenever someone says
to me this is difficult you can't do it
that motivates me then twice as much
there's nothing that we do and that
should really be scary because I'm not
afraid of failure so if the me was like
kind of like okay if people think that
it is difficult to work with kids I mean
animals I'm one of as many animals in
the set as possible
and as many kids as possible and I'm
gonna show them that it can't be done
and it was it's difficult but we do it
Ivan was just a genius direct and he
knew how to control the kids and then he
had asked me that when there was
downtime and it was time for setting up
the new shot to hang with the kids and I
think was the smartest thing because I
was not an expert with kids I've made my
own kids yet this was kind of really a
great way of learning how to deal with
kids and how to entertain them now to
make them trust you and then just like
out of nowhere out of all of this kind
of commotion and fun with the kids
you know of a sudden Ivan I saw I've
been going like this that he's roaring
and we just continued on they're having
the fun with the kids so we can have a
very successful with the children they
were great actors and some of them
became the great actors later on and so
on
[Music]
but what I liked about
Kindergarten Cop was that it was a very
brutal movie in the beginning the hunt
down this drug the Lord and there's no
good guy it gave me the opportunity to
come in as the toughest cop and then
have to develop this other side of me
because I'm not stuck with the kids I
have to now deal with the kids I cannot
deal with them like I did in the
beginning like I would deal with the
grown-up but you know I I realized
that's not the way we really to deal
with the kids that you have to
understand them you have to communicate
with them and you have to also you
didn't grow a certain love for them in a
certain heart for them and then what I
was able to show the softer side or the
more feminine side of me and so that's I
think what's made it really work well in
the movie it's not a tumor that's been
robbing
well interesting enough my motivation
there was originally to work with Joel
Schumacher I thought that his style of
directing was so brilliant and there was
a certain kind of intensity they always
in his movies but also certain
casualness so I watched him one time and
I said directing and I saw his style and
I loved it when he always said to the
actors and the and he says let's do one
for the artists meaning like do you own
take whatever you want to do and I
thought it was just fantastic because
every act that was once in kind of his
own way a take rather than being
directed or controlled and and children
provided that and the other thing was if
George Clooney was a upper coming star
in the national star he was brilliant to
work with it was very very nice and then
we learned of a guy to work with so we
had a great time the only thing was that
that being mr. freeze I had to sit for
five hours in makeup and getting all
this outfits on and everything else
every single day so it took a lot of
discipline and a lot of hard work
completely
I just finished a movie eraser for
Warner Brothers and they were so happy
with my performance in the eraser that
they came to missus would you play
opposite of George Clooney and play the
main villain you know the Jack Nicholson
display the Danny DeVito is played and
so on
then if a long list of great stars and a
faithless kind of rose and I said yes I
mean I read the script I thought it was
a very entertaining a great script and I
said yes
jingle all the way what again I was very
heavily into the idea of doing one
action movie where we used the biggest
guns and the biggest actions and the
biggest amount of killings and stuff
like that but then again to come back
with something totally opposite which is
a very entertaining movie because of its
comedy the Christmas movie a jingle all
the way was one of those great scripts
that was offered to me and I thought
that the world of it you know me just
running after this toy and then running
in and having someone trying to do the
same thing and the obviously creates a
huge fight between us so there was
action there but very comedic action and
very touching also because I'm trying to
satisfy my son that they'd have promised
that this turbo man toy and so it was
all about that that the craziness of
chasing that Christmas is around the
corner and I have to get it now and
they're sold out and all this kind of I
interested a great time doing that and
it is thought the day the favorite
Christmas movie that people are playing
and every single December this movies
being played on television and overseas
also did extremely well on your way out
just tell it would be a few minutes late
but you shouldn't worry but they cook it
down now a lot of times people have me
repeat the line you know this can you
say deadline but it's again one of those
things you know you say it and you have
no idea but I remember czar standing
there and screaming but they cook it
down now you know it and people just
loved it predator
predator was an interesting project
because it read really well it was very
intense but was it was an ensemble piece
it was very clear that there will be
like you know five six guys who went
going into the jungle and did with the
screen time would be split up amongst
all of us to me I think that in the
beginning I was hesitant about that idea
and then when I was actually in Mexico
and shooting in the jungle as it was
unfolding the story
I enjoyed it more and more because it's
so much fun to work with a bunch of guys
like that they were all really cool guys
and they were easy to work with and
there were certain thin AMEX that
everyone had and developed and I thought
it was brilliantly written Sean McTernan
who directed the film has only directed
one other film beforehand which I think
was called nomads
and so it took a lot of faith from the
studio and from all of us but the man he
pulled it off he was so good in
directing he was so thought for with the
way he moved the camera to make it
suspenseful indoors the atmosphere
created in the jungle with that fog all
the time it was kind of scary and never
to show the predator until the very end
I thought that was just brilliantly done
and it was just unbelievable the amount
of action that allowed me to do you know
this is where of course where we had
this line stick around in a way I just a
guy came up in the right side of me and
I saw me my peripheral vision and they
took my knife nailed him through the
heart and he could stuck in this pole
and I said him stick around and as I was
just another one of those really cool
lines that I liked that I made up in
this particular case
[Music]
it was really amazing when I when we
finally showed the predator and it was
created by Stan Winston who was one of
the most brilliant kind of makeup
special effects guys I think they didn't
want the Academy word twice and stuff
like that but he built that and he
created that and it was like so well
done it was really tall and had a
basketball player and that it was like
seven foot two that was carrying this
kind of you know mask and and his outfit
it looked scary too slimy it looked
weird it looked so bad that I he came
natural to me to say you are some ugly
mother you know calf did they became
kind of natural it was kind of
improvised deadline and then they kept
in the movie
[Music]
Total Recall
I was after Total Recall for many many
years
Dino De Laurentiis owned the movie and
he was going to do it with Jeff Bridges
so I was very happy when Dino De
Laurentiis had financial troubles at one
point and had to sell some of the
projects and one of the projects he sold
was the you know Total Recall I called
the you know Andy Vanya and Mario Kassar
immediately and I said you got to buy
this project for me that afternoon when
I called them they bought the project
from Dino and at then I ran into Paul
Verhoeven a few days later it was like
oh like meant to be I ran into Paul
beare over a few days later in the
restaurant and I said Paul I just saw
Robocop it's unbelievable said what a
great job you did I said would you ever
want to work with me and he says
absolutely I said well I maybe have a
project for you can I send it to you so
then the afternoon I had karoku get in
touch with him said to his agent that
the script he fell in love with it he
came on board and that's how the whole
thing came about he was smart also to
take it to Mexico because Mexico City
has it's a fantastic location very
futuristic kind of buildings and looks
to it that you can use and also you're
very free to use the city and there were
great great benefits there and great
workmanship also and I think the film
came out fantastic
he was 53 million dollars or whatever
the budget was for those days it was a
lot but today it is not really that much
and it opened up to a huge box of his
success he's almost like 30 million
dollars of the opening weekend and he
made one hundred and thirty million
dollars domestically and worldwide
almost three hundred million dollars so
it was really very very successful and
people are very happy with her with the
way it came out and he tried to copy it
some of that the remake of it how stupid
is that
I mean he's
go Hagan you got what you want give this
people air my friend in five minutes you
won't give a [ __ ] about the people fired
up doc excuse me doctor
so you gonna remember any of this not a
thing oh really
yo Sheeran son was a hard-working
actress you know she really made me
shine in a movie
she played this wife of mine that was
doing evil things to me and I couldn't
wait to get rid of her you know then it
was the famous in a scene we were
finally shot her as a considered as a
divorce there was at one of my favorite
lines consider that a divorce true lies
well again we were very fortunate to
have Jim Cameron I showed him a French
movie
Latu Tao which was a million dollar
movie was made four million dollars in
France but the concept that was there
was so brilliant Jim saw it and he says
let's do it you know which is very hard
to do for Cameron to commit the movie he
fell in love with and he went out and
wrote the script and he wrote it of
course huge as you can see took us six
months to film we were all over the
place you know from Los Angeles
Washington and Miami and the keys and
and I mean everywhere but it was
wonderful to work with Jamie Lee Curtis
because I knew Jamie liquor isn't skied
winter and Sun Valley so we have a home
up then Sun Valley and so we knew each
other very well so when she was hired I
was very excited about it because I
thought that she was really she's a
really good actress so it was great to
work with her in this film and I think
that she's also very very funny pours
off the comic that the comedy in the
movie because that the whole thing was a
very intense movie but it had his funny
moments
that the very fact that my wife did not
know what my job was and that I as the
husband did not know that her desires to
do something similar there like that to
be a secret agent so I think that's what
made it really funny
yes it's hairy
I know it's explained but I can explain
were you actually riding a horse in
those scenes yes so I would say there
was only one who was seen which was a
jump of a fountain which I'm happy it
didn't do because the professional
horseback rider wiped out and dead and
smashed his head and had like in the
20-some stitches on his face because of
it so right away there's something off
there because it was so wet and horses
then slip when it's wet and so I said
I'm not gonna do it let someone else do
that particular thing but every other
scene in the elevator
on top of the rooftop as through
Georgetown in Washington through the
park off the scenes were done I am I
rode the horse terminated dark fate you
know and in Terminator you know I can do
this Terminator movies From Here to
Eternity the trick of it is is and I
think it's very smartly done the body
underneath the endoskeleton the metal
skeleton all that stuff stays the same
so the abilities his abilities that stay
the same but outside the flesh age is
just like any other human flesh does so
that makes me get away with looking
older and to know that you can do a
movie like that 30 years later that's
the great thing about the writing and I
love to in the Terminator movies
especially when there is continuous
growth in the character and what you
will see in this terminal is that he has
been just like in Terminator 2 where
there is a little bit of human behavior
that he starts adopting and this one is
even much more that has certain kind of
effect the way he was programmed at what
point does he override his own
programming laws off those kind of
issues we're dealing with in this movie
says really fascinating you mean well
written again Cameron was involved with
that and as you know that I'm just I
think the world of his career dividend
is his thinking and his
talent and so he's very passionate about
terminator got involved with it's got
Linda Hamilton to come back to the
project wrote her into the project as a
main main character and so we had a
wonderful time with Tim Miller directing
it I can see you're very upset I'm going
to help you protect the girl you know it
really doesn't make any difference to me
I think each one has advantages and
disadvantages I think that it's the
advantage of playing a hero
obviously is that you the heroic guy
that wins and I ant and all that stuff
as a villain you have the advantage that
you can go all out then to things that
you normally cannot do as a hero because
it would not be a certain thing you can
be certain cruelty or the way you kill
people and all that stuff that's why
this was was attractive about being the
Terminator
because he's a machine so he just steps
out with toys he just you know and that
you know goes and rips out your heart as
I have shown in Terminator 1 so he will
just tear your head off and wouldn't
think twice about blood squirting around
or anything like that isn't that's what
is concerned so everything it doesn't
even show in his face any satisfaction
whatsoever when he kills five people
within one second and people really
enjoy watching villains and watching
kind of nasty things being done where
they say oh my god I have to close my
eyes I love that there is nothing that
they love more than when I do a film and
I've seen it in Terminator we've seen it
in Total Recall where certain things
that people just close their eyes and
says I cannot take it you know because
that is really than entertaining it has
been a great honor for me to be involved
in a movie where you get voted as one of
the top ten heroes but at the same time
one of the top villains I don't think
there's anyone out there that has been
but in that kind of
category before I don't really have a
favorite because I don't know really
what the definition of that is you know
for everyone is different
I think undoubtedly that my favorite of
making of the movie was twins in
Kindergarten Cop we were laughing the
whole day it was entertaining like being
with Danny DeVito and twins of being in
kindergarten cop with a bunch of kids
that always kind of throw you off
because they always say don't work with
kids and don't work with animals but
that I had the greatest time working
with those kids it was really fantastic
and you know you gives it in a lot of
space for improvisation because the kids
are improvising they're not staying with
the script they wouldn't even know how
to stay with the script so I think it
makes it very lively so I had the
greatest time doing those two movies but
when it comes to my favorite many the
outcome then you have to add also of
course True Lies or Terminator that some
of the Terminator movies that they have
done if it's one or two or the last one
dark fade you know there's a whole bunch
of movies then that come into that field
but it's very hard always to just say
this is my favorite well thanks very
much for listening to my kind of spiel
about my iconic characters that they've
played for missed any of the movies
we're gonna talk about it maybe in the
future okay hasta la vista baby
[Music]